and I have to do this baby I'm sorry
okay anyone following me and my destiny
voyage knows that I have never been to
the lighthouse I did Friday Friday and
this kid high fixed hy fi KZ your name
is Brett he's from Vancouver and him and
this kid named cool kid brought me to
the lighthouse and it was everything
that I dreamed of what did you get I got
um an ornament for my arms and then a
couple of like a banner and so like I
got like a head piece or something and
then um I want more you go back I need
to go back we tried yesterday but in the
question so like do your other friends
that you were playing with like Danny
Garcia since they didn't take you to the
lighthouse like do they feel a little
betrayal from you
no because they went to the lighthouse
today and twice already but they don't
have that they can't it's not I'm so
terrible that I can't it's basically
it's three versus three but when you're
playing with me it's two versus three -
because I'm terrible I'm shooting into
the sky I'm running in circles
they're really bad I don't there's some
matches what I don't see anybody like
I'm just dead yeah I don't know what
happened you know and they go you know
yeah you're running in circles and then
they stabbed you in the neck absolutely
terrible but this guy - was the best
player I had ever seen in my [ __ ]
life and so I'm giving us a shout-out I
did give him I donated to his um and
then I'm but I said I'm gonna give him
50 from now on each time yeah
it's pretty good deal you know and
anyone listening right now the same deal
goes out to you if you want if let me
might listen to me right now
Brice and everybody in the room and I
know people don't play destiny and you
don't give a [ __ ] or whatever but what
I'm saying to you is anyone listening
I'll give you 50 bucks to take me to
[ __ ] lighthouse Pay Pal let's venmo
what however you want to do it but
that's how and if this is the Mike this
is when I get enough pieces I'm gonna
quit the game oh damn because then I'll
have everything and I'll be bored well
baby I wish that you had gone to
lighthouse Drive you crazy
no but then you know you had promised
before that you weren't going to scream
anymore because it was causing me a lot
of anxiety so lately you've been really
up in your screams okay I make a point
to do silent yells you know like keep it
inside I might get a stroke or something
but um you have been making the point to
do that what's wrong know the pain when
you're screaming you know I do I I like
yeah but um what's up with you Gilbert
not much you're so not open we need to
grill this guy Sweden grill yeah expert
here's the thing with you know Burt is
the last couple of months you've been
coming on this podcast you haven't been
talking about munch you come in you came
in with a bunch of packages hey you did
you don't really say hi yeah what time I
said hi to you you push the other ground
what yeah the timing was wrong what's up
Bobby whoa what the [ __ ] my on the
ground have done it then
[Music]